hi I'm valeroleski and today I'm going  to show you how to style  hi I'm Valero lupovsky and today I'm  going to show you how to style this crew  neck three ways  so first way to wear it is with trousers  to make it a bit more business casual I  love pulling color from any details that  there are on the sweatshirts here we  have the true okay second look we can  always go back to our favorite pair of  jeans ballerina Flats they're back you  heard it here first and then it's all  about the art of layering playing around  with color when you have basic color  this is a great opportunity to bring a  color that you love that will upgrade  the look yay and the third look is all  about the moment where you feel so  comfortable in your sweatshirt that you  absolutely do not want to take it off  all you need to do is add a pair of  cigarette trousers and a little heel and  they will never know this is a look